let's see if we can get some some
experience converting from a decimal
representation to a binary to a
binary representation and let's start
with a fairly straightforward example
with a fairly low number let's see if we
can convert the number 13 in decimal to
binary and i encourage you to pause the
video and try to work through it out on
your own so i'm assuming you've had a go
at it so the key here is to see if you
can deconstruct the number 13 as the sum
of powers of two and then it becomes
very straightforward to represent it in
binary because in binary you're
essentially saying well what what powers
of two do you need to make up this
number
so let's just write the powers of 2 here
just to remind ourselves and i'll go
until we go right above 13. so 2 to the
0 is equal to 1
2 to the first is equal to 2
2 squared is equal to four
two to the third is equal to eight
two to the fourth is equal to sixteen
and i'm above thirteen so i'm definitely
i've had i have all the powers of two
that i need to construct thirteen
so what's the largest power of 2 that is
less than or equal to 13
well 16 is too large well it would be 8.
so i could rewrite 13 as 8
plus
5.
now 5 is not a power of 2 so i have to
keep deconstructing that what's the
largest power of 2 that is less than or
equal to 5. we see it right over here
it's 4. so let me rewrite that it's 8
plus
instead of writing 5 i'll write 4 plus
1.
and then the good thing is
1 as a power of 2 we already see the
largest power 2 that's less than or
equal to it is 1. this already is a
power of 2. so i've now rewritten this
as a
as the sum of powers of the sum of
powers of two notice this is
two to the third whoops
this is two to the third power
this is two squared
and this is
to the 0 power
or i could write it like this i have 1
i have 1 8 clearly i have 1 4
1 4
or and i should say and and i have one
one
so i could add these two i could add
these three together 13 could be
considered 1 8 plus 1 4 plus 1 1. well
why is that helpful well now let's just
let's go let's go into binary mode and
think about what what each of the place
values represent
so
this is the ones place
that's the ones place
and then we could go to the twos place
two's place every time we go to the left
each place we multiply by two it's the
next power of two
then we go to the fours place
fours place
and then we go to the eighths place
eighths place
eights
and in binary i only have two digits
zero or one so i either have zero of a
place or i have one of it so let's go
through it how many ones do i have well
i have one one so i'll write that there
how many twos do i have well in this
representation i don't have any twos the
way ever i have an eight i have a four
and a one so i'm gonna put i have zero
twos
how many fours do i have well i have one
four
one four and how many eights do i have
well i have one eight
so 13
the decimal represent the 13 written in
decimal or 13 which is a decimal number
if i were to write it in binary is one
one zero
one